when you were 13 you faced kasparov
uh and he wasn't able to beat you
can you go through that match what did
that feel like how important was that
was that how epic was that
we played three games uh i lost two and
i drew one
right but one draw no the one draw um
and but didn't you say that you kind of
had a better position in that yeah i
remember that day very well there was a
blitz game this was a rapid tournament
and there was a blitz tournament the day
before
which
determined
the the pairings for the rapids and for
people who don't know
super short games are called bullet kind
of short games are called blitz
semi
short games are called rap yeah
and classic chess i guess is like very
super long yeah uh yeah basically bullet
just never played over the board so in
terms of where the board chess blitz is
the shortest rapid is like a hybrid
between
classical and
blitz you need to have the skills of
both and then classical is it's like the
blitz tournament which
didn't go so well uh like i got a couple
of wins but i was
beaten badly in a lot of games including
by gary
and so
there was the pairing that i had to play
him which is pretty exciting so i
remember i was so tired after the blitz
tournament like i slept for 12 hours or
something then i woke up like okay i'll
turn on my computer i'll
search chess space for kasparov
and we'll go from there
so before that i hadn't spent like a lot
of time specifically studying his games
it was super intimidating because a lot
of these openings i knew
i was like oh he was the first one to
play that oh that was his idea i
actually didn't know that
so i was a bit intimidated before we
played then of course the first game
he um arrived a bit late because they
changed the time from the first day to
the other which is a bit strange and but
everybody else had noticed it but him um
then he tried to surprise me in the
opening i think like psychologically the
situation was not so easy for him like
clearly it would be embarrassing for him
if he didn't win
both games against me
then
like i was spending way too much time on
my moves because i was playing kasparov
i was double checking everything too
much like normally i would would be
playing pretty fast in those days
and then at some point i
calculated better than him he missed a
crucial detail and had a much better
position
i couldn't convert it though i knew what
line i had to go for
uh in order to have a chance to win but
i thought like i'll play a bit more
carefully maybe i can win still i
couldn't
and then i lost the second game pretty
badly which
it wasn't majorly upsetting but
i felt that i had two black games
against caspar both in the blitz and the
rapid and i lost both of them without
any fight whatsoever i wasn't happy
about that at all that was like less
than i i thought i could be able to
to do so
to me
yeah i was proud of that but it was a
gimmick
that was like a very strong i am but had
gm strength
i was like
it can happen
that a player of that strength makes a
draw against gary once said but
i'm 13 but like
still i've felt a bit more gimmicky than
anything i mean i guess it's it's a good
thing that made me noticed uh but apart
from that
wasn't yeah and for people who don't
know i am as international master and uh
gm as grand master and you were just on
the i guess on the verge of becoming a
young youngest grandmaster ever i was
the second
youngest ever i think i'm like the
seventh youngest now i mean these kids
these days kids these days yeah
yeah no but uh
but i was the youngest grandmaster at
the time uh
in the world yeah so
there is a you know you say it's
gimmicky but there's a romantic notion
it's the
especially as things have turned out
right like oh for sure and have you
talked to gary ev since then about that
no not really i don't i think he's
embarrassed
he's still bitter you think no i don't
think he's he's bitter but i i think the
game in itself was
was a bit embarrassing for him uh so
even he can't see past
like
i think he's completely fine with that i
think like in retrospect it's a good
story he appreciates he appreciates that
i don't think that's the problem but it
never made sense for me to broach the
subject with him
yeah i just
it's funny just having interacted with
gary now having talked to you there is a
little thing you still hate losing
no matter how beautiful like that moment
is because it's like
in in a way it's a passing of the baton
from like one great champion to another
yeah right but like you you still just
don't like the fact that you didn't play
a good game from a garrett gary's
perspective like he still is just
annoyed probably that yeah he could have
played better and we did
so we did work together in 2009 quite a
lot
and
that corporation ended um
early 2010 but we did play a lot of
training games
in 2009 which is
interesting because he was still very
very strong
and at that time it was fairly equal
like he was up playing me quite a bit
but i was i was fighting well so it was
it was pretty um
pretty even then um so i mean i
appreciate those games a lot more than
some random game from when i was 13. and
i maybe i just don't know what i'm
talking about but
i've always found it
at least based on that game you couldn't
tell that i was going to take his
that i was going to take his spot like i
made a
horrible blunder and lost to an uzbek
kid in the world rapid championship in
in 20 uh
18.
and i mean granted he was part of the
team that now won gold in the chess
olympia but he wasn't a crucial part he
barely played any games like it wasn't
like i would think that he would become
world champion because he beat me i'm
always skeptical of those who said that
they knew that i was going to be world
champion after uh after that game or at
all at that time i mean
it was easy to see that i would become a
very strong player
everybody could see that but to be the
best in the world or one of the best
ever it's true
it's it is hard to say but i do remember
seeing messi when he was 16 and 17.
uh
but hasn't that happened with other
players though yeah but i i pers i just
had a personal experience
he did look different than
there's like magic there you maybe you
can't tell he would be uh
one of the greatest ever but there's
there's still magic but you're right
most of the time we're trying to project
we see a young kid being an older person
you start to think okay this could be
the next great person then we forget
when they don't become that yeah exactly
that's i think what happens
you